you do s'excuse aujourd'hui on se trouve
être mika sur rock et chic pour faire du
deux contre deux n'est ce pas oui c'est
très bien c'est très bien j'adore ça
c'est mon style viril mais dans ce match
il a sauvé ses mots jp chien balle au
bras c'était bien voyager les enfants
gardent la main elle revient pas du tout
ouais mais comme je te la fais je te la
fais je te la fais ah oui je garde ma
passion arrêté sept balles le gardien
était pourtant bien présent sur le
terrain butt
j'ai toutes les cartes but de folie quel
but de folie medias des charges de chef
médical où j'ai touché la balle j'ai
touché la main ryan howard hop là c'est
moi qui mets la balle va pas tenir le
ballon
ok vas-y effectivement j'ai bien fait
c'est mon coéquipier nul donc du coup
j'en attrape sa bêtise alors alors je
note là on peut pas si tu te sens tu
centre le petit roman il vend du rêve du
rêve à 56 km heure cette balle était si
puissante qu'elle aurait pu faire
devenir un chat avec eux poil achats
sont un poil à la bientôt ta gueule à
tout va et je veux pas te faire leurs
gammes l'âge n'est qu'après des faux
faux 17e bal blanc heureusement je
l'attrapé métis aller dans les plus
brefs délais le dribble grippe au label
nato au
au hazé créer une corrida ne tient qu'à
moi ou ma joue tout le temps collectifs
mais vu que tu es dans les cages bassam
a fait marquer un but quoi voilà est-ce
que tu es métis collectif métissé
non mais tu y as milk un homme égale le
jour mais arrête de glisser [ __ ]
change t + 2 à la fin ils sont au lit
j'ai bien trouvé par les airs bika
escalade même paroisse il s'emballe
inouïe aux plats comme ça tu l'as pas
par b et c la victoire deux mika et lulu
voilà j'ai débloqué les obtenez clair je
m'en fous et effectivement on peut
constater qu'on a tous les deux mis
autant de buts l'un que l'autre
par contre il ya un truc que j'ai de
meilleurs que toi c'est le ping ça veut
dire beaucoup
les grands joueurs autant bon ping on
joue contre naruto et qui sait qu'à au
stick jamais être chaotique pour une
sorte olala et 7e balle au bond type
écarter les jambes et le petit du label
est passé le petit lu un message là mais
je n'avais jamais non
les auteurs square et on se croyait l'a
fait pour être sûr laisser les chaises
volantes dans ses magasins témoignaient
d'un sitar bonne amie tu fais semblant
de rigoler et s'ils votent ignore il
sera prêt qu'est ce qui fait que c'est
après quoi toi ne fait pas laver ça je
le mets jeu le match dommage le match 2
mai non non alors foire et au nom mika
non mika ni prendre un verre
fais-moi centre non mais oui match on
fait la revanche si on y va on y va en
revanche tu penses tu penses tout droite
ou 3gp entourant naruto arrive à fond
derrière toi fais attention il prépare à
raser de gamme c'est du vent tu as
compris oui parce que l'alsace et du
genre il a arrêté
qu'est ce qui m'arrive lucas crois
qu'ils ont mis un virus dans ma chambre
tiens on y va on y va on y va on y va on
y va de l'art fait je la refais un peu
en retrait tu la mettes eu la ola l'a71
raflé la tête dans le frigo un réchauffé
ça j'arrête cette blague tout sur le dos
je peux rien faire non mais j'ai surtout
schéma bien faire regarde ça c'est moi
bonjour howie audace où on est très
tactile dont genou oh là là non
c'était bien la tête allez on a gagné on
fait la revanche ou pas on ne peut pas
perdre ce match c'est donc la belle
alors ça alors c'est même pas un
mensonge on a vraiment fait la belle
juste avant de faire ce match là sauf
que ça a pas mal sera pas capturé voilà
comme par hasard il marque son père plus
tard la balle revient tu là mais c'est
pas grave on y vendait ce que je serai
pas pour toi tu vas tu vas tu vas t'y
vas tu vas tu y vas 7e belle est
exceptionnel c'est que j'allais débuter
comment on a pu rater ça après tu ose
critiquer mon jeu alors là je tire ma
révérence et mon chapeau 1
oh la vache ou est ce que je le mets
[Musique]
je me cache oppose la manette je te
laisse jouer je sature a comme au statut
comme l'ossature
non mais là me casser mais plus red même
moment il faut se ressaisir mika ben ali
la paix d'amiens en tout cas à le poteau
là-bas la mer vous avez compris la
merlette il dribble mais on te regarde
montre nous comment bien jouer son jeu
mais sur lui comme saint prime
tu lui as mis entre les groupes qui
l'avaient contre 50 et le pire et c'est
la victoire 5-1 quelle belle finale ont
résulté de cette de la vraie paix si la
belle d'avant c'était super c'est resté
beaucoup plus joli et on pourra jamais
rétablir la vérité sur cette belle si si
j'ai les premières images du début du
match
regardez c'était troublant c'est une
belle preuve ok c'est parti cette fois
on a lancé une partie classe a laissé sa
gare minutes c'est les 5 minutes où on
défonce tout monsieur lucas au chat oui
c'est moi vous l'aimez bien faire les i
c'est pour toi
alors ça c'était beau ça j'ai tout vu oh
tiens je te la fais c'est du mythe aura
j'ai juste vu taper dedans jaffa chargé
du je te la fais à la maca rage quit à
bas du coup c'est nul je fais vraiment
d'un pics des tories a quitté le match
et du coup quand c'est comme ça tu veux
m débute tranquillement comme ça j'ai
dit comme ça hop là et je le pousse et
comme ça y est déçu mais je vais le but
est juste buts et avec un couteau comme
ça tu dis moi ce que tu aimes pas que
jean marc blatter allait venir les
regarder la star d'un soir est vital de
ce blessé quoi franchir trois trios
trois tirs s'étirer en rigolant certains
tweets lire super tetris ok alors ou
trop bas les gens certains de ces
notions requête et vos compagnies demi
kalu uche te baise tu m'appelles ses
marques et alors mais savoir garder
n'hésitez pas aimé la vidéo ça vous a
plu [ __ ] rock'n'chic jouer à moi
j'avais joué que seul finalement comme
quelqu'un qui m'a qui joue le seul et
c'est beaucoup moins fun seul que à deux
avec un ami j'ai entendu puis c'est tout
le temps pourquoi il fait des pubs on se
retrousse attendant une prochaine vidéo
n'hésitez pas à distinguer des vidéos ni
quand et s'il n'en fait pas dans cette
pratique telle crise
oh non
[Musique]